so what were we speaking discussing last
week remembering which type of moves we
were speaking about yes our D fall
signals and actually in a type of
intermediate moves right we mentioned
there are four signals or so so instead
of just repeating what we said let's
look at more puzzles that have well the
big similarity to last week ones and I'm
not going to say a word I'm just going
to allow you to tell me well what do you
think is the best move for example for
like in this position you will raise
your hand and then I will see usually
two three four hands and then I will
allow someone to answer I won't ever
want to think so if you have an answer
raise your hand in okay rook takes be a
check and then after he is going to take
the work okay so then you will take the
rook on f6 why not take immediately the
work on f6
so that will be just exchanging of works
right and in the way that you've
suggested white is going to win material
how much exactly exactly and that is
basically what we just mentioned as an
intermediate move something between the
series of captures we want to have we
see there are several captures in the
position we see that there are several
captures but how to benefit the most
from that that's the big question if we
will simply say well yeah there is a
real free look well we have to think
about our opponent move each and every
time okay actually not only white got
nothing no this one can be dangerous
okay it cannot advance right now but
maybe in some situation the knight can
come
and support it maybe the 19 come and
support the advance of the pawn or shut
the bishop away
well white has to be careful moving his
business so the pawn is not gone and
just become a queen yet rook takes b8 is
just winning the game immediately we are
taking with the check and after King
take White is a pizza excellent so check
is one is demons pulsing move right
because by the rules of the game the
opponent has to have to react to it okay
we have done several of dog let's do
let's do one easy one and then some oh
well few easy and then few difficult
let's say this was the position let's
first start if it's white to play which
moves should white play here if it's
white to play
it's the only piece it can take Quinn
textbook and then some piece is going to
be okay and then what we you will play
okay so instead of just playing instead
of playing immediately the move will
take work well the opponent is just
going to take that is take when the
opponent is going to take the Queen and
that's basically exchanging okay I can
still take a pawn but you won't first to
play Queen takes on g8 and after take
you want a rook okay excellent now let's
flip the boat whenever we are solving a
puzzle whenever we are solving a puzzle
we want to look at it from the side that
is to play so now we flip the board and
it's black to play and what is the best
move for black in this position the very
best move for black bless you okay I
understand the idea but now let's see if
you will play this move we spoke here
and mentioned many times many times
that's excellent for it's not a right
move but we are going to bring back a
topic that I said we have to mention a
thousand times or more does white have
to take your work you gave the book we
don't have to take what the opponent is
giving for example if white is to play
in this position
why wouldn't white take the Queen take
the Queen you will take now his queen
and then it will take your work and you
wanna look so white will choose what you
want to take how to take you are correct
in the sense that if white was forced to
take the work your move is very smart
but he is not forced to do that so walk
h1 white doesn't have to take yes
you wanna answer quaint Oh
No you want to try yeah
Queen takes f1 that's interesting this
move it's almost working but now let's
let's think and let's think let's see if
we can play the right way even without
moving the pieces I will be nice and put
an arrow Queen takes rook this is the
idea of black to take the route what
should white play here what should be
the best move forward
yes the other will be captured hmm yes
Queen textured okay we have to at any
given moment count count the material on
the board we have to we have to white
black took a rook black took a look if
you will just simply recapture maybe
it's the best move but if it is the best
move Dan White is lost if you will
simply recapture the black will capture
the Queen and black is upper book black
walk black one the work that was here is
upper work so it's actually now White's
turn to say hey before I'm going to
capture your queen and then you can
capture my Queen for free I can capture
your walk with a check a check black and
not movie screen cannot capture why - it
has to capture back and then and white
one day walk so now it's equal material
he lost this work before anyone that won
this this is exactly type of
intermediate move that we are doing here
yes
Quinn takes it to you in a pond there's
something better yes
check basically whenever we play a game
this this is going to be you know I
don't know how many of your games I'm
going to see next to your next two years
next five years next ten years hopefully
you will play for much more and maybe I
will even get to see a lot of those
games you will have endless amount of
games that many pieces will be under
attack and many times very very
high-value pieces then I'll know high
higher value pieces than the Queen's in
both Queens right now are under attack
both Queens are under attack black queen
is under attack from this rook and white
queen is under attack form this rook
both Queens are under attack just
capturing gonna gonna give black nothing
so what should Black's first objective
be black should think if I can move my
queen
away but not allowing white to movie
screen or white will pay a price for it
then it's very good for me not just
moving the Queen if you just gonna move
the Queen if you just gonna move the
Queen okay white is just gonna move a
screen you didn't gain anything in that
way but if you can move your queen
without allowing white to move a screen
then you will win a lot of material and
what is the most forcing move in chess
the most forcing one yes a check you
know you can threaten your opponent
Queen it doesn't have to do something
most likely you will do something but it
doesn't have to do something silly to do
you can threaten checkmate okay maybe
he's going to have something more forced
but when you threatened check that's it
the opponent has to react by the rules
of the game he has to he has to either
move block or capture he has to so if
your queen is undertaken to opponent
queen is on the attack also if it lower
value pieces your first objective will
be how can I move my queen without
allowing the opponent to move and that's
why Queen a5 is winning nothing but the
Queen is winning the Queen you just
threaten a chair the king is going to
move somewhere for free pretty much for
free that that is the best types of
intermediate move that we can help
what should I play c4 McNutt can just
move this bishop now but the Queen the
Queen here is protected so you're it's
not even a pin that you're gonna win
something okay
yes what should I play rook takes knight
on f6 that's also a decent move to
consider yes
anyone else yes an ev3 that's also a
move
yes but looking for I can just take it
but if we can fold the point is just
going to take your work you're just
going to give quite a lot of material
you don't want to just give quite a lot
of material Adi well okay the king is
going to move then what
you take the knight so why aren't you
taking the knight right now very very
good very very good very very very good
that's why you suggested b3 before right
but you found a better way than b3 once
I can see once again that that that's
very very good
look c4 is actually is actually losing
why c4 is losing exactly because of same
idea that we mentioned before black and
just move his bishop in his gonna be
okay but black is going to move the
bishop to e fo and black is threatening
check and threatening the Queen and the
King cannot move to defend it and if the
rook moves we will just take the rook
wouldn't be able to capture because it
will be pinned it will be pinned exactly
so this is going to cost you a queen the
first question that White's should ask
himself first question should the try to
Dasom surface there is a free night
always when you play chess first things
to look forcing moves that are sometimes
going to be checked but nobody won a
game of chess saying well I checked my
opponent ten times any resign it doesn't
work that way
check gives you something and from that
you want to get something but you
and say oh I captured two weeks I was
two books up and then I want again so
first question to ask is what happens if
you want to take their night you have an
inode yo you have a night for three so
if you play a game and we actually
mention it before we mention it in all
previous classes when you see a position
that you can capture something for free
your first instinct should not be yeah I
can take the night for free what should
be your first instinct yes
why can't I capture the night for free
what wonder it I I know I know this what
there is that I don't see you have to be
very very suspicious well why can't I
capture it it looks really great
that's the answer in this position some
positions by the way what happens if you
can capture something and you do not
find any reason why you should not
capture it then you should capture it if
there is a reason that you didn't know
well you better study more for next time
and if there is no reason then you'll
just capture something for free so here
we are looking at this position and that
is going to be our next topic excellent
what happened if we captured the night
for free
well then Adi kept mentioning the bishop
is going to take the pawn on a to check
and what is so important about this
check nobody is protecting yes and how
can we spot those things we first have
to spot pieces that are not this is the
tunnel protected and then how can we
attack them white is going to take the
beer shop bless you and then there the
queen is going to be captured exactly
you know how to win chess games right
winning material is a big start so white
is going to play so now look what white
needs to find white wants to take the
knight it's very simple you just work
very simple the way of thinking
sometimes not finding an answer if you
think correctly you will tell yourself
okay so I want to capture this night for
free right now and I want to avoid
losing their Queen Jodha scoffs so you
can say oh I'm gonna move my queen okay
beautiful you move your queen and I will
capture the knight but what do you think
the opponent is going to stand there
looking pretty and just waiting for you
to capture the denied so you will move
this night so we want to be able to move
our queen in a forcing way and not allow
him to move his Knight and for that we
need a check so we find check black is
gonna move is king and then we're gonna
take let's look at one very very nice
puzzle last one about intermediate of
the buck all those checks captured salsa
move and then we will tiny bit start
looking at discover check add enough
money okay this is a really cool
position I really really like it white
is to play here I want to see I'm gonna
give you two three minutes here I want
to see if white if you I know why how I
should play I want to see if you one of
you can tell me the entire continuation
how I should play not just one move okay
I will let you answer first but I want
to see Mohan what should be the entire
continuation for white in this position
okay I want to see hand whoever has an
answer you answer first one
yep
yeah
you you you tell me you wanna take the
pawn okay
the walk will take and then you take the
Queen okay
no not bad you want a pond you want a
pond okay wait you want to talk not bad
now the same way the tree said the same
way that we said hey whenever we have a
good move good idea something that we
think on and we're not gonna win
material we have to think what the
opponent will play on the same line we
have to think what we have to think do
we have something better we have to
think if we have something better the
fact that you see something that is okay
you want a pond you play this and you're
winning a pond maybe you have something
maybe if you have something better what
do you have better this time
okay Queen takes bishop now it so you
want to take the bishop okay so it
captured basically say story at one of
the puzzles that we were looking before
to Queens under attack this will happen
in many many of your games whether it
will be to Queens under attack other big
pieces under attack just just happen to
work the bishop oh it it happens many
many many times
it's okay okay so what will happen if we
will take the bishop now if I will take
you will take the Queen okay but black
and clay black will take the bishop
himself let's let's see I'm just gonna
put arrows yes what will you play then
take black we'll say oh okay now both
Queens are under attack I don't want to
take and let you take my queen for free
I will take your bishop so so then if
you will take my queen
I will take yes okay check check once
again two times in a row the Queen's are
under both of them so now what is going
to remind you what's going to be our
next topic discovered checks and what
what is the idea of a discovered check
Adi you tell me since
you give a check in your attacking
another piece so what is the goal the
goal is like in many many other goals is
to is to win material the goal like many
many other positions would be to win
material for example we can have you
know let me let me give you I will make
a tiny bit tricky but this is one of the
most important patterns in chess this is
the position and it is black to play
this is tricky I would suggest you to
take little bit I'm thinking here should
black capture this pawn or not this is
really very very important pattern
why not let's actually yeah but that was
actually perfect but that was actually
perfect but well where is the black
queen going to be you you used the word
eventually and instead instead what we
should see is this we should be very
very concrete when we can analyze
something right when we can analyze
something clearly we have to be very
concrete if like I always I like this
example actually many people say right
things but meaningless what what was not
the right thing but meaningless means if
you ask someone how much is five times
five and he tells you it's more than ten
but less than hundred is he correct but
it's meaningless okay beautiful so when
we look at something in chairs its first
of all sometimes we cannot actually say
hey this is it and does it matter if
it's a beginning a master a grand master
or the world champion just it's just
impossible even it doesn't matter even
if you're a computer that calculates 1
billion position of whatever more per
second sometimes there's just so many
possibilities well we each get our
evaluation of thinking well why it's
better black better same way that a
computer will always show what is
thinking but it's not concrete but our
aim should be always to get as concrete
as possible why say that you were
correct but should have drop the word
eventually because if black will take
well should we look at captures false
captures we have to so white will
capture so now black can do whatever he
wishes but he lost two points of
material you can do whatever he wishes
or you can take and then exactly what
you mentioned is correct exactly
one of the most important basically the
most together with another discovered
shape most important discovered pattern
in chess check and where is the queen
the queen is on d4 not on da so that is
excellent the same by the way would be
absolutely correct if if there was no
Castle wife there was no castle it would
be exactly the same thing because the
bishop would go to well perfect exactly
exactly exactly exactly and how many of
those are happening in chess games in
young kids play infinity endless you
know you name it take take take
okay black one a pawn is Queen is
undefended check and winning the Queen
exactly that pattern and you reach it's
really on this point that's being
undefinable
yes Adi
yes but but is it yes you're right
so black is not going to lose a queen
for a pawn is going to lose the Queen
for a bishop in a pond but we as justice
do not care about that right yes it's
the you wanted to say something for no
95 for whom yeah but like right now is
the possible move like when 95 for white
or black this move wait let me allow
white to move one second you mean this
move okay but actually now maybe black
indeed can take because now no problem
it's defend it's defended and just for
example okay if it's white to play by
the way probably it's best not just
objectively let's say it was a game of
two strong players maybe we'll see one
is a decent move bringing the rook to an
open file probably bishop before is also
deserve a lot of attention just very
good spot for the bishop by the way does
anyone know the name of this pond yes a
deep pond but something more about the
different it's just of the deep on it is
yes yes but in this specific position it
gets a different one it's the same in
all notation D instead of they didn't
have the files ABC so they just named it
based on the original pieces yes
isolated yes
so almost exploding right okay it's
isolated isolated deep oh it's it's a
big term interest and because we get we
get such a structure for many many
openings actually many of the best
players in the world pretty much Jeff
when Calvin Carson and everyone in
Kramnik every world champion is played
many many many different games in his
life
with this structure where the white or
black what does it mean isolated there
is no pawn from left side no pawn from
the right side White's pawns no points
but there is at least one pawn on the
side from the opponent at least one of
those pawns but is there blocking this
pawn to advance usually now now we will
go to national geography is it better to
be in a group or is it better to be
alone if you are trying to survive in
nature what do you think alone my
goodness
alone you don't want to see some hungry
some angry wild dogs or I don't know
other types of animals if you're in
nature
no we what you want to be in a group you
want to be you want to be in a group we
will recommend some natural nests some
National Geographic TV no we want to be
in group because then it's not very easy
for example to a predator to attack an
innocent deer or whatever so then it's
much better tiny bit the same we will
take you to chess a bit less violent but
yeah broken pawns or broken pawn
structure porn islands is is not you
don't want to have many because this
point is alone it's a weak bond this was
just three minutes about general chest
knowledge isolated pawn and isolated
point of considered weakness because
they are alone they don't have anything
to defend or protect them for example
wouldn't that look so much prettier look
this is a very strong pawn chain this is
the base of the pawn chain black and
berry can basically touch
it how can you attack it okay can move
its Queen but we can easily defend this
and everything else is defended
extremely well as opposed to moving this
pawn the C pawn and then the D pawn is
all by itself kind of weak so this was
one part of very very important pattern
of isolated pawns and that will be our
topic now we have an easy topic for next
week to look at many more ISIL many more
note I thought upon discovered checked
and discovered capture and I'll see you
next week